Travis Scott's 1.4 million dollar push
present for Kylie Jenner as their
daughter stormy makes her snapchat debut
plus we're with crystal and the ladies
of the bachelor after last night's wild
women tell off I have got a serious case
of the Mondays my friends and Kylie
Jenner's epic push president is also
making me re-evaluate my life you guys
see what Travis Scott got her the guy
dropped some serious coin gift in his
baby mama this 1.4 million dollar
Ferrari I'm not even into cars and I'm
like damn apparently only 500 of that
model exists and Kylie and Travis now
have a sick ride for their afternoon at
Nobu Malibu that's where the two were
spotted on Saturday it's the first time
we've seen them together since welcoming
their baby girl earlier this month
and speaking of stormy also made her
snapchat debut Kylie shared this sweet
video of her newborns tiny toes and
clearly she can't get enough cute little
feet we didn't get a full look at stormy
but Kylie has been slowly sharing bits
and pieces of her private life again on
social media meanwhile her sister Kim
Kardashian nearly broke the internet
again this time debuting a drastic new
do they say blondes have more fun but
what about pink
Kim literally has pink hair now it's so
extra but I kind of love it
what do you guys think of Kim's new hair
hot or not alright well how's this for
some heat last night's The Bachelor
women tell all will go down as one of
the more insane in the best way possible
specials and recent franchise memory why
because the show's villain who I've
dubbed crazy Krystal was dragged when
they aired unseen footage of her slammy
bachelor re and the other women and let
me tell you Krystal was not having it
our girl lauren zima
was there for it all
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we saw some footage tonight that we
hadn't seen before of some names you
called are in the other women did you
remember that what was your I did not
know you owned that do you apologize for
that what are you yeah you don't wanna
say it it's just I was having an
intimate conversation that was caught
through the peeping tom of my hotel room
when I'm in the bathroom that was caught
through the room I was just really upset
and hurt me and I was just like I felt
it my teammates that were very
disrespected and I felt that we should
take a stand and show re the him pulling
back his word him dangling a carrot for
us to dance and perform and then pulled
it away it's not okay with me
and I would never tolerate that in the
real world she won't tolerate it folks
all right so the big question why are we
just now seeing this footage well he
spoke with Robert Mills and ABC
programming exec about the bombshell
moment and he said it wasn't held for
women tell all
and things get cut for various reasons
but they didn't realize at the time the
impact crystal was gonna have this
season well thankfully that footage has
seen the light of day so what do the
other women think of the footage which
was also new to them head over et
online.com slash daily denny to find out
all right and finally Marissa Jaret
Winokur is 250,000 bucks richer
after winning Celebrity Big Brother the
show's first winner ever
now she banded together with runner-up
Ross Matthews who had some success of
his own get all that crazy Donald Trump
teef of all her OSA in the backyard
remember the one
it's bad
should we be right well our very own
Bryce sander talked to Ross about that
headline-making moment which he'd even
no saw the light of day something I was
thrilled about this season watching you
you put your investigative journalism
cap on and got stuff out of Omarosa I
don't even know if that air did that air
I deserve some sort of Pulitzer Prize or
something right I got the dirt did that
that aired people saw it it was every
single episode there was a nugget from
Omarosa what was your reaction to
hearing all that stuff I was just
thinking this is gonna be huge outside
the house you know what I mean I felt
like you guys sent me there to get to
get it out of her until I was on a
mission
I'm so happy people saw that oh yeah cuz
I'm getting stuff in the backyard going
dude gold
they better be putting it on the show
when she told you that we should be
worried and scared around the world it
was like oh so that with me yeah you're
welcome
yes Thank You Ross you know we also got
all morose as reaction to that
conversation and we'll also have that up
at et online.com so I stay lead any for
you okay
we did it we survived Monday I need my
tea thanks for watching
[Music]